hace una conversación sincera extensa y
profunda ha desvelado la prensa china ha
sido también la primera vez que hablaban
desde año nuevo chino y habría sido
solicitado según la casa blanca por joe
biden desesperado por la falta de
avances en las reuniones de los equipos
negociadores la situación pues exigía
mayores compromisos de entendimiento y
eso es según las dos versiones lo que se
han cruzado los presidentes joe biden ha
subrayado la necesidad de que la
rivalidad no derive en conflicto
mientras si sin pin añadido que mantener
unas buenas relaciones bilaterales es un
deber mutuo que además beneficia al
mundo china y eeuu comparten interés en
áreas como la lucha contra el terrorismo
el coronavirus o el calentamiento global
y la salida de donald trump permite
ahora un mayor grado de colaboración
pero también hay otras áreas que
aseguran las fricciones como hong kong
taiwán o el mar del sur de china además
pekín en las últimas semanas ha
lamentado que job alden no frenará la
guerra comercial que había emprendido su
predecesor o la huida
las tropas
estadounidenses de afganistán dejando
atrás un caos que ahora tienen que
gestionar los vecinos